bienvenue à paroles autochtone ici c'est
mélissa mollen depuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question de magali qui me
demande est ce que le mythe de
pocahontas soutient et encourage les
violences faites aux femmes magalie
c'est une très bonne question j'en ai
souvent parlé j'ai souligné le fait
qu'il y avait un problème avec
pocahontas c'est qu'il y avait le mythe
de pocahontas
il y avait l'histoire de pocahontas le
mythe souvent liés à ce qu'on a vu dans
le film de walt disney pocahontas très
sexy avec la robe que juste une épaule
qui sont d'une falaise qui est très très
courbé
une des erreurs princesse de boldin et
qui a une mini jupe très très courte et
fendue sur le côté et à l'histoire de
pocahontas c'est l'histoire d'une jeune
fille qu'on estime avoir entre 10 et 13
ans à l'époque qui sauvent et justement
john smit celle dont celui dont elle est
tombée amoureuse dans le film mais elle
l'a sauvée contre une mort certaine si
ce n'est de sa communauté
sauf que son histoire est plus grande
que ça ensuite elle s'est fait kidnapper
été capturé par les colons de jamestown
elle a été mariée à un homme qui
s'appelle john rolfe qui était un des
premiers importateurs de tabac en
virginie et elle n'a même pas eu la
chance de pouvoir finir sa vie sur son
propre continent car elle est morte en
angleterre elle est enterrée la mort
d'une maladie pulmonaire
l'histoire de pocahontas est quand même
très tragique parce que c'est une
histoire d'une jeune fille qui avait
même pas encore fini son adolescence qui
étaient victimes de violences physiques
de violences sexuelles qui ont été
déracinés et le mythe c'est l'histoire
d'une jeune fille très sexy qui court
dans la forêt qui parle au colibri et ça
l'a amené l'idée de la femme au temps
comme très libérée sexuellement très
quand je pourrai dire très facile aussi
malheureusement ce mythe continue aussi
avec les histoires qu'ils étaient
rapportés au québec par exemple par les
missionnaires comme quoi les femmes
autochtones était très libre
sexuellement avait eu le droit de
choisir leur partenaire et salle a
contribué à dire que les femmes étaient
les femmes autochtones était très facile
aujourd'hui on voit aussi que ce mythe
continue perdure puisque la quantité de
femmes assassinées disparu au canada
proportionnellement à celles qui sont
autochtones aux autochtones on sait que
les femmes autochtones
que ce soit au canada ou aux états-unis
sont les premières à en être victime
et c'est souvent lié à cette mythologie
qui a nourri l'histoire au québec au
canada et même aux états unis
alors oui je pense que le mythe de
poquitos nourri ces violences là je
pense que l'histoire véritable de
pocahontas permettrait justement de
prévenir qu'on continue à avoir ces
idéologies fossiles
donc merci beaucoup magali pour ta
question j'espère que vous allez nous en
envoyer d'autres
j'espère aussi que vous allez partager
ses vidéos je vous souhaite une très
belle semaine